e
e e
and uh welcome to Public Works uh as I
understand this will be our last uh work
session for our committee uh we're here
to deliberate on four house bills um the
only motion that'll be brought forward
today I think a little differently than
the past is either to recommend for
future or to not recommend for future
legislation um I'd like to recognize
representative Murray for joining us
today and um sitting in for
representative alone thank you welcome
to public
works all right our um our first uh
first piece of business is House Bill
110 prohibiting the use of State funds
for new passenger rail
projects and with that I recognize
represent Jack for a motion uh thank you
Mr chairman I move not recommended for
future legislation I'll second
it motion's been made and seconded do
not recommend for future legislation
House Bill 110 is there
discussion I've I've been told that that
this legislation's being entered again
you know anyways at this point in time
for the next session so good luck with
that so uh see yes
Madam
yes for for discussion I think no matter
what the topic is my opinion is that
it's poor legislation poor governance if
you say no no matter what it is we're
not going to ever do it um things happen
good things bad things unexpected one
way or the other and uh so I I just
think it's poor legislation poor
governance to have any legislation that
is a blanket say no to a um to something
like thank youim Newman any other
further discussion seeing none would the
clerk call the role please thank you Mr
chair representative cluder uh yes
representative Mills votes yes
representative fedolfi
representative Newton is not here
representative kazinski is not here
representative Bowen is not here
representative Boyd Bo vot I
representative
Melvin yes representative bogert yes
representative Connor is not here
representative Jack yes representative
Abbott yes representative Edgar I
representative fauler yes representative
Newman yes representative Eaton
yes representative Peterson is not here
representative
Murray
yes representative jurus
yes chairman
mcon chairman votes I Mr shair the vot
is 15 motion carries thank you
sir we'll move um excuse me Mr chairman
does this does this a consent or regular
calendar for these
recommendations I don't know the answer
to that okay I mean I would request if
his consent what I'm
sorry okay thank you thank
you okay we will move on to House Bill
606 requiring construction of state
buildings or state funded projects to
contain electric vehicle EV charging
infrastructure with that I will
recognize representative Boyd Mr
chairman as a relates to House Bill 606
FN I move not to
recommend motion's been made and
seconded
discussion Mr chairman uh I like the
principle of this bill and I've talked
with the prime sponsor but I think it's
too broad it talks about apartment
buildings and it talks about State
construction projects I personally would
like to and I express my I'm willing to
work with a prime sponsor if you want on
maybe a SE a separate bill or even two
separate bills it's just too broad the
way it's written but it's I I in
principle I I have nothing against EVS
but I'm going to vote to vote to not
recommend based on the way it's written
thank you hey uh
yes I'm also in favor of the bill and
concept but I recognize that it's not
likely to get much support the way it's
structured and that we shouldn't be
spending the time spinning our wheels on
it so I I agree with representative cler
thank you representative pner any
further
discussion yes
please thank you Mr chairman um
as putting the EV charging
infrastructure in a lot of apartments
and stuff as it was been mentioned as
we're looking at trying to create also
affordable apartment
rentals uh adding cost that someone in
that framework of looking for affordable
housing is not going to be buying
$100,000 EV so with that in mind we must
move carefully as we're trying to create
affordable housing and apartment rentals
and also requiring more regulations to
add cost so please be cautious about
that okay thank you representative
represent
fuler just couldn't help but take the
bait I don't
Eevee I'm very happy with it I paid
$27,000 for it and there certainly are
more and more used EVS now so it's not
just the high-end Market anymore and
we're now at 7 or 8% of the of the
market and and in growing
so some of the past assumptions based
upon the early
uh early entries into the EV Market
aren't going to hold up much longer so
I've just wanted to okay thank you put
that in any any further
discussion seeing none clerk would you
please call the role yes Mr chair
representative
cluder yes representative Mills votes
yes representative fedolfi
yes representative Boyd Boyd votes
I representative
Melvin yes representative bogert
yes representative Martin Jack
yes representative Abbott yes
representative Edgar I representative
Faulkner yes representative
Newman yes representative Eaton
yes representative Murray yes
representative jurus yes chairman mcon
uh chairman votes I Mr chair the vote is
155 in the
affirmative thank you
our our third piece is House Bill 488 FN
relative to Hazard mitigation funding I
recognize representative
Mills Mr chair I vote I I recommend not
recommended for future legislation
seconded motions made and seconded is
there
discussion yes yes yes with all due
respect to everybody here I plan to vote
against the motion of not recommend and
the reason why I'm voting against it we
we have had a problem over in my neck of
the woods Sullivan County maybe chesher
County and one of the communities I
represent in addition to Claremont is
cin and last summer and I think again
this past summer there were heavy rains
which flooded out a lot of cin a lot of
aworth which rep the prime sponsor comes
from and other communities and I think
the prime sponsor made an attempt to try
to rectify this is trying to make to
make Rectify this situation A Hazard
mitigation fund would maybe prevent some
of these disasters from happening again
and I realize it's it's not a lot of
money but I think we begin begin need to
do something to address this issue again
and I believe she's going to introduce
the same bill again but I think in good
conscience when I'm voting against this
I'm trying to represent my cin
constituents thank you thank you m thank
you represent cluder I I will just add
to that that U uh many of us have had
these terrible events and continuously
having these events and I think I think
my misgiving on this is that it was a
bill involving funding and coming in on
on a non-budget year so I'm glad they're
going to bring the conversation and LSR
forward and I think the appropriate
places in the new budget any other yes
please thank you Mr chair uh I'd also
like to add that when you look at the
bill and what the cost would be of they
estimated at
400,000 and that the payouts to the
given towns would they have some real
surveyor problems it's only 50 Grand
that uh the concept I think is good but
the uh disproportionate payout for the
for what it cost is at this point I
think is not wise thank youer further
question further
comment uh seeing none clerk please call
the rooll thank you Mr chair
representative cluder uh no
representative Mills votes yes
representative fidy
yes representative Boyd boy votes sign
representative Melvin yes representative
bogert
yes representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes representative
Edgar I
representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman yes representative
Eaton
yes representative Murray yes
representative jurus
yes representative makoni chairman votes
I the motion passes Mr chair
1415 thank thank
you thank you r m the uh last piece of
um that deserves our attention is House
Bill
1547 requiring mileage based exit
numbers on tier one highways and I will
recognize representative Boyd Mr
chairman thank you as it relates to
House Bill 1547 I move to not
recommend motions made not to recommend
is there a second second
second by Mills um
discussion yes represent
fuler uh recognize that this isn't
necessarily a bad idea it's just
something that should be taken up as
part of the uh Highway Transportation
10year plan then I think this was
uh wrong bill at the wrong time and
we'll deal with the you Department in
terms of where that fits in
priority thank you I concur with your
comment clud yeah is there someone from
do here for a question by any chance I
think we have three all right okay uh
just the question is there about a
mandate to do this and if so what year
are we supposed to do
it
button thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Bill oldenberg I'm the director of
project development for New Hampshire
dot um the
requirement to do this the exit sign
numbering was part of the mutcd update
starting in
2009 where it was required or well it
was
recommended um but in the the last
update in 2014
it was
required um and
just bit of History we have put in a
bill or put in a a project in the
10-year plan um since then we've gone
through six cycles and um that that
project in the 10year plan has been
removed either by the governor or
through the gaset
process thank you follow up uh yes if we
don't do this is there will we lose
Federal Highway
funds there's the potential um but right
now it's it's
a they they note that we we don't comply
they ask what we do and they accept um
currently they accept the fact that the
our legislative process either e either
um through the house or through the
governor or through the the asset
process we are unable to to to do this
so they accept that um right now um ma
majority of the state
so a little bit more history is most of
the country does exits by mile post
marker um New England was was basically
the loan hold out that did it
consecutive numbering system like we
still have the the group of states that
are have consecutive mile marker or mile
exit numbers is slowly
dwindling um and soon it'll be will be
the last one standing I think um so
that's where I think the spotlight might
come on us so thank you president bar do
you have a question are you satisfied
represent FL here uh yes thank you res B
please thank you uh I've noticed on 93
on the south end headed towards uh
Massachusetts that we're building a new
bridge or it's almost completed and
we're putting a new exit in uh out of
curiosity with our numbering system The
Way It Is What would be the number for
this new entrance exit ramp on to 93
it's going to be called Exit 4
a but under the the new mile post marker
it would
be um I think I wrote that down actually
no I didn't somewhere around 145
something like that
all right thankk you you all you settled
there you all set representative all
right any further any further questions
for the Department thank you gentleman
for coming thank you okay thank you Mr
sherff
um all right so um a motion for House
Bill
1547 I recognize represent
boy second Mr thank you so we we're
ready to uh call just one further thing
chairman what would that be Mr uh okay
the bill is written there is no fiscal
note in the bill so even if the state
would say we were going to do this and I
would prefer the feds do it if they're
mandating what's the cost of doing this
and also it says not until 2035 uh I I
don't know by 2035 what the cost of this
will be for the feds or for us we don't
know with inflation so I have some real
concerns about this and the way I'm on
the study commission and we've got to uh
get more money for a highway fund so
until we're until we're forced and if
we're forced the feds better pay for it
my opinion preferably through the
10-year plan I'm voting no well I will
vote Yes to not recommend thank you
thank you represent
cluder uh clerk please call the rooll
thank you Mr chair representative cluer
uh
yes representative Mills votes yes
representative faly
yes representative Boyd Boyd votes I
representative Melvin
yes representative
bogert
yes representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes representative
Edgar I representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman
yes representative Eaton
yes representative Peterson yes
welcome you're welcome thank you
representative Murray yes representative
jurus yes chairman mcon chairman votes I
motion passes Mr chair
1605 right four sorry four that's why
the first number changed
1604 thank you so we have uh we have
concluded our business for Public Works
and highways and I appreciate your
Indulgence before we go I'd like to take
a
moment um I want to recognize uh some of
our esteem members representative Abbott
uh representative Newton is not here
today but I understand he is running for
a county commissioner position so we
wish him the best represent Connor had
called earlier he will not be returning
wanted everyone to know his appreciation
for the
committee um
and representative Oden's not here he
will not be
running um I'm so glad you showed up
representative Peterson um thank you and
no no longer returning so um we you will
be missed by this committee uh I wish
you nothing but the best going
forward and um and
um if there's anything yes represent I I
think we missed one very important
person I think I have it in my notes
Here
uh representative makoni is not going to
be so thank you so I I um I'm I'm going
to take a moment to Pine here so um I
have had nothing but pleasure in serving
this committee and serving
you I have served under uh Smokey Smith
Jean Chandler Candice
buard uh David Campbell and John Graham
and no matter what party has sat in this
chair it has always been the same that
there is not partisan bone in this
body I thank you for that I'm so proud
to be a member of this and I hope to uh
hope to see you wandering the Halls uh
next year so with that I I honestly
thank you for your time and I thank you
for the so many well- wishes that so
many have brought from my family thank
you excuse me Mr chair may I may I as
your Vice chair I've enjoyed working you
we've had some a few disagreements but
we've always settled them Amic and most
of the time we've been able to come
together in a compromise and I really
appreciate that and I think that's what
makes this this country work and this
committee is a model for the rest of
this house in in my in my opinion I will
I will miss you good luck in your your
Senate campaign and who knows we I we
maybe you know hopefully you'll come
back once in a while to testify on on
either house or Senate bills and um
hopefully we can continue working with
you again uh next term uh but as I said
in any case regardless it has been a
pleasure to work with you and has made
my legislative experience a lot more uh
enjoyable thank you thank you
representative and thank all of
you
yay for